I have to think you hold a special place
in your heart for John Lennon and Paul
McCartney because when the stone started
out those dudes gave you your first hit
song and I can't even wrap my head
around that nor can I why would they
even be kind enough to do that I don't
know it's kind of I think that they they
felt that they were part and that we
were part of something larger and that
that England was
finally uh coming out with something and
I think they wanted to support us saying
we're not the I mean they Big Hearted
yeah I want to be your man yeah they
came and flogged it to us and we said
well take that here's the Beatles
[Music]
version and they gave it to you like
this and you guys put the spin on it
Rock and
R did you once say to John Len and John
you wear your guitar up too high yeah I
always did I told him it was bad for a
posture there was the Liverpool posture
you notice that nearly all the Liverpool
guitar players played it up there I
thought they were just being cheap on
the
strap by a kid strap get a longer one
couple of bucks you and Ronnie Wood I
mean you keep those guitars almost down
by where it's comfortable for me I mean
it's I I can never understand that
doesn't it also look cooler Keith if you
want to be a good guitar player got a
long strap baby it's
true